[Music]  lady Perry brought to tears on American  Idol the popstar got extremely emotional  during Monday's auditions after hearing  25 year old David Francisco's story I  moved to Nashville to do music in 2016  and then I actually got hit by a car and  paralyzed from the waist down thankfully  through physical therapy David has  regained some feeling in his legs not  only has his physicality improved but  his love life has - after the accident  he reconnected with an old friend who's  now his fiancee Kristi she joined him at  his audition David's performance brought  the judges to their feet no surprise  here et spoke with all three judges in  January Katie told us why she's so  excited to find the next big star the  point is to find American Idol and I  think to reinvigorate the public that  that real dream can come true again and  I just I so much believe in that feeling  and I know it will inspire other people  as being on that journey is the key word  [Music]